자 드디어 최종 4예 가음 주가
마지막이죠 맞지 자 어땠어요 좀
문제가 좀 쉬웠어요
어네 오케이 자 쉬운 듯하면서도 아마
답을 못내는 경우도 많았을 거야
아니면 너희들이 답이라고 생각하면서도
놓치는 경우도 있었을 거야 하지만
이번 모의고사는 좀 쉬운 듯하지만
글을 놓치면 돼요 안 돼요 안 돼요
이번 서부터
살펴보겠습니다 자 초록색 빨간색
노란색 상자 중 고색 구슬이 들어
있다고 한데 세 개의 상자 중 한
개의 상자에 적힌 말만 3이래요
그리고 나머지는 거짓말이래 그 우린
여기에서 생각해야 되는 거야
뭐냐면 문제는 어느 상자에 비어
있는지 맞지 구이 구슬이 들어 있지
않은지를 생각해야 되잖아 칠판 보세요
자 그러면 두 곳에 구슬이 들어가
있으니까 한 곳에 구슬이 들어가 있지
않겠지 이건 결국 무엇을 찾는 문제야
우겨서 모순이 되는 걸 찾아야 되겠지
자 첫 번째 빨간색 상자가 참이라고
해보자 그러면 초록색과 노란색은
거짓이 돼야 되겠지 자 빨간색이
했어요 초록색 상자에는 구슬이 있다
그럼 여기에 있어야 되겠지 그럼
빨간색 상자에는 구슬이 없어야 되겠죠
근데 여기를 봐봐 빨간색 상자에는
구슬이 없는게 맞는데 빨간색 상자의
구슬이 없는 것이 거짓 이래 그럼
말이 돼요 안 돼요 안 되겠 얘는
된다 안 된다 안 된다 안된다 그럼
두 번째 초록색 상자가 참이라고
해보자 그럼 빨간색과 노란색이 거짓이
되겠지 그러면 빨간색 상자 초록색
상자에는 구슬이 없는 것이
되겠죠네 자가 얘기한 빨간색 상자에
구슬이 있어야 되겠지 또 빨간색
상자에 구슬이 있어야 되겠지 그럼
참이 됐어요 안 됐어요 됐죠 그래서
답은 초록색 초록이 답이
되겠습니다 이해
됐나요 어렵지
않았죠네 다 하세요 와 한지 둘 다
하세요 자 2번
봅시다 1부터 9까지 수를 한 번씩
사용을
했대요 그랬을 때 무엇을 구하라고
했어 아래 식을 완성하세요라고 했어
물론 이런 문제는 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 해서 하나하나씩
지어가면서 쓰면 되잖아 근데 여기서
확실한 힌트는 뭐가 되겠어 4가
되겠고 얘는 6보다 작은 수가
되겠어요 안되겠어요 근데 4도 쓰면
안 되고 5도 쓰면 안 되잖아 그러면
써
보면은 7이 되겠지 그리고 얘는 답이
두 가지가 나와요 98 1이 될 수도
있고요 얘가 1이면 얘가 8일 수도
있겠어요 없겠어요 그래서 둘 중 하나
답을 쓰면
되겠 자 그다음 다음 그림에서
쌓기나무를 쌓고 위암 옆에서 봤대
얘들아 우리가 보통 싸키 나무의
개수를 셀 때는 어딜 봅니까 칠판을
봐야죠 딱키 나무의 개수를 셀 때는
위에서 본 바탕 그림에 이렇게 써
주죠 맞지 그러면 여기는 무조건 1
1이 되고 얘는 3이 되고 얘는 2가
돼야 되잖아 근데 별이 보여야 되잖아
결국에 얘가 2 2 3이 돼야 되고
2 2 3이 돼야 되겠죠 그럼 얘가
한 개 한 개 한 개가 더 있어야
되겠어 없어야 되겠어 그래서 답은 몇
개가 되겠어요 세 개가
되겠습니다 자 그다음
4번 자 4번 문제는 바로 무엇이
되겠어요 거꾸로 해결하기 있니다
얘들아 거꾸로 해결하기는 표를 그려서
해결하는 문제가 있고요 글에다가 쓰는
문제가 있어요 근데이 4번은 글에다가
거꾸로 풀어주는 문제가 되겠어 안
되겠어이 나요 자 그러면 얘가
302에 1을 쓰고 30이 남았으니까
60이 우리가 아기 때는 어떻게 됐어
이렇게 거꾸로 그림 그려 가면서
했었잖아 자 에이 이제 다 컸는데
굳이 이렇게 되겠지 그럼 얘는
480 cm 자 4m 80도 맞았다
해
주겠습니다 자 5번
자 강광 순례는 옛부터 추석날 밤에
여자들이 손에 손 잡고 둥글게 원을
그리면서 춤을 준대요 마주보는 문제지
자 이런
문제는요 자 이렇게 나한테 맞춰
풀이야 간단히 만들어 풀이야 1 2
3 4를 써 보는 거야 맞지 그랬더니
차이가 얼마야 2지 차이가 있데
인원은 몇 명이 예요네 명이 됐죠
그럼 얘는 어떻게 풀 수
있어요
어 어 그렇지 차이의 두 배가 전체가
되겠어요 안
되겠어요 자 그러면
45와 18의 차이에 몇 배 두 배가
되겠지 그럼 얘는 27 * 2가 되는
거잖아 답은
53명이
되겠습니다
자 6번
봅시다 방 기호와 예시를 보고 주어진
기호를 숫자로 나타내 보세요라고 했어
자 이거는 지난주에 했던 거랑 비슷
무리한 문제야 그 직각삼각형 규칙이
있었던 문제
있었잖아 자 그럼 얘는 1이고요 얘는
더하고요 요거 그림을 찾아보니까 2가
되겠지 그거 그림대로 써주면 되는
거잖아 얘는 3이고 더하고 1이
빼기고 얘는 2가 되고 얘는 더하기가
되고
아 잘못 썼어 곱하기가 되고요 얘는
1이
되겠지네 아 그니까 뭐야 5가
되겠지요 자 그런데 선생님이 이거는
뭘로 풀라고
했어 계산기 계산으로 풀려고 했죠
계산기 계산으로 풀면 얘는 10이
되고요 근데 아까 음수도 써도 된다고
했지 원래 계산했어 - 6이 되겠죠
그래서 둘중 하나 답을 쓰면 맞았지만
보통 황소 문제는 음수가 답이 될 수
있어요 없어요 안 나올 거예요 그래서
계산 기수라는 걸 의심해 봐야
됩니다 자
7번 얘들아 관호 양면 모는 종에
그림과 같이 양면과 뒷면에 같은 수가
오도록 순서대로 수를 썼대 자 얘들아
이거는요 맨날 틀려요 그지 근데 사실
황소 시험에 색종이 접기 많이 안
나와 왜요 많이 안 나올 때가 많아요
하지만 안쪽에 있는 것이 위로 가는
건 알아야 돼 몰라야 돼 그럼 봐요
이렇게 접었을 때 얘가 안 쪽이지
이렇게 접으면 여기가 안쪽 이렇게
접으면 19하 20이 안쪽이라 말이야
자 그런데 문제는 뭐야 마지막에는
가장 위에 쓰인 걸 찾으라고 했잖아
얘를 이렇게 위로 덮어주니까 답은
20이
되겠습니다 자 8번 아까 보니까
은근히 점수가 높아서 많이 풀었던
학생도 8번에서 규칙을 못 찾아서
해을 친구들이
많어요 맞지 자 얘는 내가 피보 수열
문제를 만든
거였어 자 얘는 세 개를 더해 봐요
부가 됐어요 안 됐어요 자 이렇게 세
개를 더했을 때 그다음 수가 되거나
연속하는 두 수를 곱해서 그다음 수의
1의 자리가 되는 규칙 같은 문제들이
여러 개가 있었지네 이거는 일반적인
수열이 아니라 약간 함수 암호화 같은
문제인 거야 그러면 얘를 이렇게
더하면 1의 자리가 6이 됐지 문제는
17번째를 구하라고 했는데 13 14
15 16 17 그럼 더하면 여기는
4가
되겠죠 얘는 더하면 얼마야 3이
되겠지 얘는 0이 되겠고
7이고 답은 0이
되겠습니다 자
9번
9번은과 차의 배수 문제 또는 프
과정에 차를 산 뭐 이런 문제가 될
거예요 자 그럼 얘는 어떻게 되겠어
얘들아 여학생을 나는 동그라미 할래
남학생을 세모 할래 근데 어떤 학생은
이렇더라 선생님
세모를 전체가 36명이 36이
동그라미로 해도 되지 않아요 그렇지
하지만 이거는 바꿔 해결하기 맞지
또는 1차 방정식이 되니까
그거보다는 연립방정식 방법이 더 편
거야를 이용한 계산 사인하는 양팔
저울 계산 그럼
봐 일곱 장씩 나눠줬어요
남학생한테 다섯 장 나눠줬더니
12장이 남았어 자 그다음 문장에서
표현이 어려운 친구들이 있더라
여학생한테 여덟장 남학생한테 일곱 장
여기까지 이해 됐지 자 그런데 여학생
다섯명이 색종이를 한장도 받지 못했대
그럼 다섯 명이니까 40장이 필요가
없는 거지네 그럼 빼기 40이 되는
거야 자 그다음 스텝은 일곱 개씩
양팔저울 지우듯이 지워봐 다섯 개를
지워봐 그리고 40을 더해 봐 그러면
동그라미 하나랑 세모 두 개를 더하면
52가 되겠죠 자 그런데 여기에 또
힌트가
있네 우리는 남자랑 생만 이 다른
성이 있는 건 아니잖아 그래서
동그라미랑 세모를 더한 것은 36이
아아 어 세모 하나 차이가 16이
되겠죠 그럼 동그라미는 20이
되겠어요 안 되겠어요 그럼 얘는 결국
7 * 20가요 5 * 16 과요
12명을 더 12개를 더하면 되겠어
안
되겠어 답은 23 이장이 되겠어
알았어요 자
10번 자 조용해 봐 얘들아
여기에서의 트릭은
집중 20층에 살고 있다는 얘기는
19층 내려오는
거야네 25층에 살고 있다는 얘기는
2층을 내려오는 거야 자
그런데 20층 고 있는 민은 학교에
가려고 나왔더니 엘리베이터가 수리
중이라서 내려갔다 어딜 내려갔어
당연히 계단을 내려갔지 그럼
진미은 19초 아니 19층에 4초씩
걸리겠어요 안
걸리겠어요 자
선민은 30초를 기다리고 2초씩
24을 내려왔지 78 그럼 여기는
48이 7초가 되겠어요 되겠어요 근데
누가 먼저잖아 그럼 진미가 2초 먼저
내려왔을 어려운
문제였어요
괜찮죠 자 11번
보겠습니다요 얘들아 바로 새로
대각선의 수해 합이 모두 같아야 된대
그럼 빈칸에 수를 넣으래 근데 얘들아
빈칸의 수을 넣을 때 a 합을
구하라고 했지 빈칸을 다 채울 필요
있어요
없어요 그래서 나는요
랄랄랄랄랄라
랄랄랄랄랄라 이렇게 선을 그려
봤어요 자 이제 아 소리가 나와 안
나와 나오지 왜 바로이 부분이 공통이
되는 거잖아 그럼 17과
38과 20을 더한 거랑 a 랑
40을 더한 것이 모두 같겠지 그럼
a + b 당연히 뭐가 되겠죠 얘가
75가 되니까 35가
되겠 선생님 그런데 그 10번 답
뭐였어요 미
2초 자 조요 몇 이렇게
소란스럽네 자
12번
얘들아
우리는 나이 문제 틀렸으면 화낼
거야요 나한테 최소한 3개월 이상
배웠던
친구들이요
맞지 어 복습이 안 됐다는 얘기야 자
집중
조용히해라 얘들아 이렇게 생겼을 때
크고 작은 사각형의 개수를 구하는
것은 세로의 선분의 개수 곱하기
가로의 선분의
개수직 거기까지 모르는 사람은 안
돼요 어 그랬으면 1031 중급 3%
1과정 공부를 제대로 안 한
거야 필드도 그런 거야 소마도 그런
거고 자 그런데 여기에 높이가 추가가
되면 되잖아 높이는 만들 수 있는
선분은 여섯 개가 되겠어 안
되겠어 자 여기까지 개수 체 번 보자
자 1부터 300까지 수 중에서
3으로서 그러면 우리가
3으로서 몇 번
쓰겠느냐잖아 그러면 100의 자리에
4가 들어가지 않고 10의 자리에
4가 들어가는 경우와 1의 자리에
4가 들어가는 경우도 이렇게 나눌
거야 그리고
가 되겠지네 이해됐어요네 그러면 얘가
0일 때를 생각해 봐 그럼 여기는
2가 시작이라서 여기서부터 3씩
커지겠죠 안 커지겠죠 커지겠죠 자
그다음 1일 때는 5가 되잖아 그럼
1부터 커지겠지 4 7 자 2일 때는
0 3 6 9 이렇게 되겠어 안
되겠어 그럼 이때는 열개가
되겠죠 그다음 이때는 또 0이
들어가도 되죠 왜 나는 1의 자리에
있는 4만 구할 거니까 그럼 똑같이
2하고 5하고 8 1하고 4하고
7 0하고 3하고 6하고 9가 나와서
열개가 되겠어요 안 되겠어요 여기까지
이해됐어요 합하면 모두 몇 번
20번의 수를 쓸 수
있습니다
자
14번
얘들아 학자가 있어요 모
모양이 굳히 동그라미 그릴 필요
없다고 했어요
대신 지나는 아무데나 있어도 되겠지
그럼 나는 여기다 지하라고 할래
지나의 오른쪽 옆에
해정이 자 그런데 이런 문제는요 이런
문제는요 필한 은 지워버려야 되겠지
그 니은을 필요 있어요 없어요 없죠
자 모건이 서준이와 친하지 않지만
서준이 오른쪽 근데 얘들아 이거까지만
봐도 알 거 같아 왜냐면 남은 애는
모건이 아고 서준이 아아 맞습니다
근데 서준이 오른쪽에 모건이 있잖아
그러면은 서준이가 여기에 있고 모건이
여기에 있어야 되겠어 없어야 되겠어
그럼 답은 누가
되겠어요
자
15번 다음 그림에서 찾을 수 있는
크고 작은
직사각형을 그럼
얘들아 여기 있는 마른모 모양과
직사각형 모양이 겹쳐 있는 사각형은
있어요 없어요 없죠 그럼 가는
직사각형 모양 따로 사각형 모양
따로가 되겠지 그럼 얘는 6 *
15가 되겠고요 6 * 6을 더하면
되겠지 그럼 12 6개가 되겠어 안
되겠어 어 얘도 겹쳐 있는 거 있어요
없어요 없죠 그러면은 1 2 3 4
더하면 10 * 10 이잖아 그리고
3 * 3이 되겠어요 안 되겠어요
근데 문제는 4가 17개 더
많습니다 답이
되겠습니다 자
16번
얘들아 어렵게 생각하면 오히려 틀리는
거야
얘는 100의 자리고 얘는 10의
자리고 얘는 1의 자리라 생각해 보자
그리고 1과 2와 3 1과 2와 3
1과 2와 3이라고
해 그럼 25가
되죠 35가 되지 그럼 얘는
113에러 친이
되겠습니다 아까 누군가 막 여기다가
15도 써 보려고 하고 막고 고민
되게 많이 한 친구들이 있는데 너무
어렵게 풀려고 하다 보니까 그런 거야
맞지 저도요 어
맞아요 자 17번은 맞아야 되겠죠
근데 너무 쉽다고
했는데 너는 맞았던 거 같은데 틀린
친구들도 꽤
많아요
자 보자 8월 1일 난 12시예요
근데 3분 늦게 간데 근데 얘들아
벽시계는 저렇게 바늘
시간 차이가 되면 되는 거야 몇 분씩
모여서 한분씩 모여서 그 12시간이
몇
분이에요
720분이지 그럼 720
땡땡이라 아이가 있거든 1일부터
10일이
지나면 8월 11일 10일이 그든
근데 어떤 친구들은 8월 10일이라고
한 친구도 있을
거야 그렇지 그리고 정확하게 난
12시도 써야 되겠어요 안 써야
되겠어요 써야 되겠죠 이해
됐나요 자 8번 8번
얘들아 이런 문제는 어떻게 해야 돼
우선 1 2 3 4 5 6 7을
쓰고요 14 중에서 안에 서로 다른
다섯 개의 수를 넣었는데 근데 아래
조건 봐봐 뭐라고 써 있어 한 자릿
수에는 짝수만
들어간대 그럼 얘가 네모 네모 빼기
네모
네모가 50일 때
네모 네모 빼기 네모
네모가 얼마야 52일 때 4라면
맞지 네모 네모
빼기 54일 때를 생각해야 되지 물론
이때는 2을 썼고요 4를 썼고요 6을
쓴
거잖아 근데 여기 1의 자리가 0이
되려면 1의 자리가 서로 같아야 되죠
그 이때는 만족하는가 겠어요 없겠어요
없겠죠 이해됐어요 자 여기에는 1의
자리가 2가 돼야 되잖아 그럼 2가
되는 경우는 받아내림이 있는 경우와
없는 경우인데 받아내림이 있는 경우는
절대 수가 될 수 없어 왜 10의
자리를 3차인 하게 만들 수가
없어서 자 그러면 여기는요 67 -
15 75 -
23 65 - 13 73 - 20 을
얘기할 수 있어요 자 54일 때는
75 - 21이 됩니다 그럼 모두 몇
가지 아 여섯 가지
우와 다섯
가지 자 이제
어때 여기서부터는 멘탈 관리가 필요한
거야 내가 너 멘탈
관리 어 멘탈 관리 너무 어려워 보일
수도 있어 맞지 근데 뒤에까지
정신줄을 꽉 잡아야 돼 어 그래서
너무 힘들었을 때는 그냥 뒤에서부터
푸는게 더 나을 수도 있어
맞지 문제를 뒤로 가면은 얘들아 봐라
아마 4. 2점 때가 너무 어려워
보여서 아 그냥 그런 난이도가 있어
우리 지난 시간에 배웠던 29번
문제인가 그 거리 속력 시간이
나왔는데 우기 문제
있었지네 맞아요 어 말도 안 되게
깜짝 놀랬지 물라 문제 맞춘 친구도
있을 거야 어 근데 알고 보면
어려워요 쉬워요 진짜이 2때 문제였
그런 식 문제들이 있습니다 자
19번도로 하지 말고
채웠는데요 가장 큰 힌트를
생각해
아니
얘들아 기역은 큰 수가 될
거야네 인데요 근데 1로 나눌 수
있어요 없어요 없죠 그 기억은
8이나으로 생각할 수밖에
없어 6 6 그래 6이라고 해보자
우선 8부터
해볼게 그러면 여기에는 작은 수가
나오면 안 되니까 4라고 해보자 그럼
2고 3이고 6이란 말이야 그럼
여기는 어떻게 되겠어 수를 빼야
그럼 여기는 5가 되겠어요 안
되겠어요 되겠죠 자 여기는 뭐가
되겠어
3으로서
되겠죠 8이 되겠죠 그럼 여기는
7이라고
해주면 1이 되겠지
아이고 5가
되겠지 중 하나만 썼으면
맞았습니다
자 지금 빨리
써 자 21번 아
20번 그림과 같은 관역 화살을
맞췄어요
아 그런데 봐라 0점 1점 3점
9점이 있지 그럼 - 1 - 3 -
9도 있지 그럼 0점 1점 3점 9점
- 1 - 3 - 9 이렇게 각각
만나는 거야 안 만나는 거야 만나는
거지
얘들아 그러면 나는 얘네들이 서로
만나는 거거든 그럼
봐라
자 검수가 더해지는 경우를 생각해 보
그럼 최소는
1점이 최대는 10점이
있지 아 최대는 얼마야 18점이
되겠어요 안
되겠어요 그럼 1점 만들 수 있고요
2점 3점 4점 5점 안 되지 6점
7점 안 되지 8점 안
되지 아 8점
된다
맞지 그다음 9점은 돼요 안 돼요
되지 10점 되지 11 안 되지 12
되지
그다음 아니 점수를 얻는 경우 하나
둘 셋 넷 다섯 여섯 일곱 여덟 아홉
열 개가
되겠네 그럼 당연히 빼지는 경우도
당연히 가지가 되겠어요 안
되겠어요 그리고 0점이 되는 경우 한
가지가 되겠어요 안
되겠어요 답은
21가지 여기까지 이해
됐나요네 자 그다음
21번 자 아 제박 선생님이 옛날에
그런 얘기한 적 있다니 찾기를 가면
내가 무슨 얘기 할 줄 알고 돼야
자 기차길을 가면 기차길을
그리고 산을 올라가면 산을 그리고네
호수를 돌면 호수를 도르라 그리라고
했어 그런 것처럼 의자가 몇 개가
있대요 다섯 개가 있대요 그럼 나는
의자 다섯 개 그릴래
대충 내
마음이 벤치 아니야 자 그리고 번호가
적혀 있때 1번 2번 3번 4번
5번 판을 봐야 되지 않니 오늘 새로
하거 왜 이렇게 집중 못
하지
응 늦게 왔으면 한 문제라도 더 많이
봐야지 맞지 얘들아 몇 점이 중요하니
지금 당장네 선생님 설명을 들어야지
선생님 시험은 그냥 모이고서야 이렇게
안 나올 수도 있어 근데 선생님이
어떻게 계속 함정을 하 맞지 속지
말라고 그러는
거야 근데 그 함정이 쉬은 함정이
아네 그지 잘 봐 요게 단이라고
나왔어요 1번 의자에는 세 학생 중
한 학생이 반드시 앉아야 됩니다 그럼
여기에 1번 앉을 수 있어요 없어요
어 여기에 누군가 앉아야 되는데
여기에는 2번이나 3번이 안 겠구나
자 그리고 또
생각이납니다
뭐야 같은 번호에는 앉을 수 없다고
써 있잖아 문제를
읽어야지 자 그다음 생각을 해야
돼요 1번에 2번이 앉은 가지 수나
1번 자리에 3번이 앉은 가지 수나
서로 어떻겠어요 같겠죠 그럼 굳이
3번은 생각할 필요 있어요 없어요
나중에 곱하기 2만 해주면 되겠어 안
되겠어 바보
똥들이 자 그럼
보자 자 여기 앉을 수 있는 애는
3이야 맞지 그럼 3번이 앉았을 때
2번이 앉을 수 있는 자리는 세
가지가 되겠어요 안
되겠어요 맞지 아 1 1이 앉 아
미안 한 번이 여기 앉을 때
어 잠깐 잠깐 잠깐 아 오케이 1번을
앉을까 3번을 앉을까 3번을 앉 을게
그냥 처음 했으니까 주성아 그거 안
하기로 했잖아 자 세 가지가 되겠지네
자 3번이 여기 앉을 때는 앉을 수
있어요 없어요 없지 자 3번이 여기
앉을
때는 1번 1번 1번 또 몇 가지야
세 가지가 되겠어요 안 되겠어요 또
한 번이 여기 앉을 때도 세 가지가
되겠어요 안 되겠어요 이해됐어요
지워
줘야겠다 아홉 그럼 아홉 가지잖아요
앉을 때랑 3번이 앉을 때랑 똑같다고
했지 민주랑 7 7판 집중 아홉
가지씩 두 개니까 몇
가지 얘들아이
22번은
22번은 약간 103일 입문 뒤에 뭐
그 게라 후라이 굳는 거 빵 굽는 거
뭐 라면 그리는 거 맞아 저거 폴더가
맞지
저 그거 풀었어요 어 맞아 자 그런
문제랑 같은 거지 근데 문제를 잘
읽어요 너희들이 항상요 네모 칸부터
있는데 그럼 돼 안 돼 안 돼요이
문제는 몇 사람이 두 사람이 동시에
일하는 거야 이해 됐어 자 그런데
먼지를 털지 않았는데 바닥 쓸면 돼요
안 돼요 안 돼요 바닥 쓸고 먼지
털면 청소 다시 해야 됩니다
그래서 동생과 같이 하는데
먼지를 털기를 할 때 다른 거 할
필요 있어요 없어요 없죠 왜 물건
정리하기 발 바닥 쓸기 먼지 털기를
먼저 해야 돼 아 바닥 쓸기
그렇지 자 봅시다 그럼 먼지 털기
얼마 걸리겠어 7문 걸리는 거야 그럼
바닥
기와 벌레를 빨아야 되겠
겠지 그럼 얘는 몇 분이 걸리겠어
기하고 빨기를 같이 할 거니까
10분이면 되겠어요 안 되겠어요 자
그다음에 닦아야 돼 한 명은 닦고 한
명은 정리할 수 있지 뭐 순서는
바뀌어도 상관없어요 어쨌든 20분이
걸려요 그럼 마지막에
도구정리 5분 얘들아 이런 거잖아
얘들아 얘야 동생한테 그랬어 얘야
나는 바닥을 닦 닦을 테니 너는
청소도구를 정리해 그럼 형 벌레 내놔
그럼 돼 안
돼지 이렇게 되는 거야 답은 40
2분이
되겠 이해됐어요
자 여기까지
계산 자
23번 아마
23번은 다 틀렸을 거예요
왜냐면 16 가지라 써서 다 틀렸을
거 16
가지라고 써서 틀렸을
거야
왜냐면이 답이 16가지 문제가 너무나
많았었거든요 기
학원들에서 또는 성대경 씨에서 어
성대경 씨에서 성대경 시에서도이 문제
있었어 없었어 있었어 거 같은데
모두 갖고 돌리거나 뒤집어서 색칠한
곳이 같으면 한 가지로 봅니다 말은
없었어 이해됐어요 자 우선 다섯
칸짜리 막대가 들어갈 수 있는 곳은
하나 두 군대야 그럼 내가 두 군데
중에 하나를
선택했어요 자네 개인 곳은 여기나
여기 중에 선택해야 되잖아 두 개가
되겠지 세 개인 곳은 여기가 되겠지
두 개인 곳은 또 하나 여기가 되겠어
안 되겠어 이래서 과감이
했어요 근데 얘 뒤집어도
똑같잖아 나누기 2를
해줘야
다 아 알았어 네거 신경 자
그다음
24번 얘들아 24번 문제는 잘
읽으면 돼 또 시너 불안하지 왜 누가
나왔으니까
관우랑 주연이가 나왔으니까 맞지 자
관우와 주연이는 1점 2점 3점에서
10점까지 있대요 세 번 맞춰서
점수의 합이 큰 학생이 큰
사람이이기는 거야 또요 여기에 내가
조건을 놨어요 얘들아 보통 이런 관영
문제는요 타겟
문제는요 순서가 달라도
같았었지 나올 수는 점수를 물어봤지만
노가원 선생님은
특별히 칠판으로 보세요 순서가 다르면
다른 경우를
냈습니다 이해 됐어 2번
성대경시 진짜 나
몰랐어 어 진짜 이번 성대 경시 이게
똑같은 문제가 나왔는지 몰랐어 어
맞아요 진짜 똑같은 거 나왔어요 우와
대단한데 역시 내가 먼저 했어야
되는데 자 봅시다 물론이 색깔은
달랐을 것 같아요 맞지 어 맞아요
선생님
봐봐 자 그런데 얘는 관호 점수야
관호 몇 점 맞았니 26점
맞았지 그러면
주연이는 얘보다는 커야 되잖아 그럼
조용 30점이 나올 수도 있고
29점이 나올 수도 있고 28점
27점 아지가 되겠죠 자 그다음 봐
30점이 나오는 경우는 10 10밖에
없겠죠 자 이거는 합이 일정한 경우의
수하고 똑같지 큰수부터 점점 같거나
작아지게 써 주는 거야 그럼 얘는 쭉
하지
마 일부러 이거
맞았 잖 그냥
얘기해
어 10하고 하고 8 마지막에는 뭐
있겠어 99 9가 있겠어요 없겠어요
아 맞았다 자 그런데 뭐가 나왔어
순서가 다른 경우는 생각해야지 한
가지 세 가지 세 가지 세 가지 세
가지 세 가지지 원가지 합치면
20가지가 답이
돼 뭐야 성대경 시에서이 문제
틀렸었다 아니요 저 맞았어요 아 아
저 맞았구나 네가 그거 길래 그건 줄
알았어 자 그다음
25번
자 공정 계사이 알아 자 알아 알아
쉿 사
어렵습니다 얘들아 얘는요
500원짜리가 있겠고 100원짜리가
있겠고 50원 짜리가 있겠고
10원짜리가 있잖아 그럼 12개의
동전으로 우선은 940원 만들어야
되겠지 그 우리는 필수로네 개를
쓰겠어요 안 쓰겠어요 그리고 여기는
하나를 쓰겠어요 안 쓰겠어요 그럼
540원 썼어 그건 남은 거
얼마야 400원이 400원 몇 개
일곱 개지 그럼 일곱개를 가지고
100원짜리 하고 50원짜리 일곱
개를 가지고 400원을 만든다는
얘기는
기기죠 그 원짜리가 일곱 개라면
350원 이잖아 50원 하나 차이가
되겠어요 안 되겠어요
그래서 100원짜리 여섯 개 50
아니 100원짜리 한 개 50원짜리
여섯 개가 되겠어 안 되겠어 자
그다음 읽어
보자 두 개를
썼어요
어 근데 뭘 썼는지는 알아 몰라
몰라요 자 이거는 우기기로 합쳐
가지고 만들어야 된다는 거 꼭 생각해
자
그다음 일곱 개가 남았어요 그럼 몇
개를 썼겠죠 세 개를 썼겠지 어 세
개를 가지고 200원을
만들었잖아 그럼 뭐야 100원짜리
하나와 50원짜리 두 개를 썼겠죠 안
썼겠죠요 그럼 이때 남은 것은 한 개
0개네 개네 개가 되는
거잖아 이해됐어요 읽어 봐 500원이
아닌 서로 다른 동전이 그 이렇게
썼겠다 안 썼겠죠 그럼
결론은
50000원짜리 한 개와 50원짜리
세 개와 10원짜리 세 개가 남았다고
할 수가
있겠습니다 이해됐어요 자 바로
넘어가겠습니다 자
26번 자 풀이 일정하게 자라는
목장에서 양이 있어 근데 얘들아 2물
마리가 20일 동안 먹어 그럼 풀이
몇 개가 있어야 되겠어 420만
있어야 되겠지 자 그런데 35마리
10일 동안 먹으려면
풀은 350이
아 그럼 결국
35에서 맞지 21을 뺀
나머지가 이렇게 해
줘야겠다
420에서 350만 뺀 양을
20 마리에서 열 마리를 뺀 열마리
차이가 먹는 거지 그 얼마가 낫겠어
7이 나오겠어요 안 나오겠어이 얘기야
처음에 이만큼이 나왔어 어 근데 풀이
맨날 요만큼씩 나와 근데 매일 풀을
요만큼씩 먹어 그럼 얘는 변해 안
변해 안 변하지 근데 풀을 매일
이만큼씩 먹는다고 해 봐 그럼 그다음
날은 이만큼이 자라도 얘는 자라지
않았기 때문에 또 없어지지 또
없어지지 그 어느 그럼 처음에 있던
양은 변하면 돼요 안 돼요 그럼 결국
몇 마리만 있으면 돼 일곱 마리만
있다라면 다 먹을 수가 있겠죠 그니까
계속 끊임없이 풀이 나겠지 물론
겨울에는 풀이 나지 않습니다 농담이야
자 그다음 26번 27번
어 이거는 지난주에 날 지지난주에 날
이렇게 구슬이 3대 1로 갈라지는 거
배웠어요
네 그거 문제랑 비슷한
문제지 같은 비율로 내려가는 거잖아
그럼 내가 여기를 한 개 한 개 한
개가 내려간다고 해
볼게 3이 되겠죠 여기도 3이
되겠어요 안 되겠어요 그럼 여기가
6이니 여기도 6이라 처음에 12
개겠지만 그럼 동그라미 일곱 개가
70명이 거지 그럼 동그라미는 10이
되는 거지 그죠 처음에는
120명이
되겠습니다 어려워요 아니요 풀었습니다
풀었어 자
28번
얘들아 28번은 나도 가끔씩 집중해야
될 문제야 그래서 모를 때는 뭘
그리라고 했어 그렇지 바탕 그림을
그리라고 했었지 자 보자 그런데 어떤
친구들은 얘를 검은색을 따로 구하고
흰색도 따로 구한단 말이야 맞지 아
그러면 되겠어 안 되겠어 안 되겠지
왜냐면 전체에서 검은색 빼면 무슨
색이 되겠어요 그렇지 자 그럼 전체의
개수를
보니깐요 여기는 몇 칸이야 여섯 칸이
세로는 다섯 칸이
높이는 다섯 칸이 그래서 150개가
있대요 자 그리고요 저는 검은색을
먼저 확인할 거예요 그 위에를 보니까
여섯 개가 되겠어요 안 되겠어요
되겠죠 자 그다음 보니까 x x x
x 얘가 해지겠지 그다음 여기는
x 하지
말라고 이렇게 되겠죠 그럼 봐요 여기
섯
여기에네 개지 여기에네 개지 그럼
14개가 2층이 되겠어요 안
되겠어요 여기까지 맞은 사람 손들어
놓았어요 자 그리고 얘는 지금
모르지만요 아래도 14개인 거 알아요
몰라요 알아요 자
그다음 그 아래도 한번 해 볼래 얘만
지워지면
되겠지 샤이는 이걸 얘기했을 거야
여기도
14개 그지 그요 가운데 드디어 이제
가운데를 찾아야 되는 거야 근데
가운데 짱
쉬워
시끄러 여기만 다 채우면 됐지 어 나
배신이다 맞지 내가 아까 모를 땐
바탕 그림 그리면 된다고 했는데 난
바탕 그림 그렸어 안 그렸어 그렇지
왜 나한테 화내 빵 그 자 여기는 몇
개가 되겠어 18개가 되겠어요 안
되겠어요 그럼 얘는 20개 그요
여기는 28개
그요 얘는 38개 그요 66개가
되겠어요 안 되겠어요 그럼 검은색이
몇 개 66개
me 흰색은 84개 되겠지 그래서
무슨 색 아 18개만 쓰면
되는거나
알았어요
자 그다음 봅시다 28번 쉬운
문제였지 자 29번 보세요 29번
집중 자 29번 답좀 들어
볼까
다 29번
1에서 300가지의 자연수가
있대요 우선 2가 있는 자연수를 모두
지웠다 남은 자연수에서 6이 있는
자연수를 모두 지웠다 다시 남은
자연수에서 0이 있는 자연수를 모두
지웠다 나는 이거 이렇게 얘기할 거야
0과 2와 6이
없어요 0부터 199까지 숫자카드
중이 어 자 그럼 보자
우선 두 자리 쓸 때가
있겠고 100번 대가
있겠지 200번 때는 있겠어요
없겠어요 없겠죠 여기까지 이해 됐어
자 그럼 보자 얘랑 얘 두 개가
있다라면 여기는 0을 써도 되겠지 왜
한 자일 수도 있으니까 1 3 5 7
8 9 맞지
여기는 1 3 5 7 8 9가
되겠어요 안 되겠어요 빠진 거 없나
1 2 3 아 4가 빠졌잖아
[음악]
이렇게 되겠지 그럼 이때는 8 *
7이 56이 되겠어 안
되겠어 여기는 1 3 5 7 8 9
여기도 똑같겠지 1 3 4 5 7
89 그럼 7 * 7이 돼서 4 9가
되겠어요 안 되겠어요 그 56과
49를
더하면 105개가
되겠습니다 이렇게 필요 없는 걸 빼고
생각하면 되게 쉬운 문제가
되겠지
맞죠 자
마지막 자 30번
보자
얘들아 정육면체를 만든다고 했잖아 어
그건 크기에 따라서 위에서 본 모양을
구하면 얘는 이렇게 되겠지 아 이거
너무
크다
그다음은 이렇게 되겠어요 안
되겠어요 그럼 이때는 1 * 4가
되겠어 안 되겠어 이때는 2 * 6이
되겠어요 안 되겠어요 얘는 3 *
8이 되겠어요 안 되겠어요 그다음에는
4 * 10이 되겠어요 안 되겠어요
그런데 그것이 이때는 2층에 있는
거지 이거는 세 개 층이 있겠지
이거는네 개 층이 있겠지 이건 다섯
개 층이 있겠어 없겠어 자 높이는
이때는 한 개가네 개
있겠지 두 개가 아홉 개 있겠지 왜
하나 둘 셋 넷 다섯 여섯 일곱 여덟
아홉이 세 개가 16개 있겠지네 개가
25개 있어요 없어요 이해
됐어 이게 됐어 그럼 400개로 만들
수 있는 것은 이때는 300개를
사용할 수 있는 거잖아 근데 높이에
있는 것만 사용하라고 했었지 그래서
답은 100개가
되겠습니다